when most people think of ethics or
morals
they think of rules for distinguishing
between right and wrong
such as the golden rule do unto others
as you would have them do unto you
a code of professional conduct such as
the hippocratic oath
first of all do no harm a religious
creed
like the ten commandments thou shalt not
kill
or a wise aphorisms like the sayings of
confucius
this is the most common way of defining
ethics norms for conduct that
distinguish between acceptable
and unacceptable behavior most people
learn ethical norms at home
at school in church or in other social
settings
although most people acquire their sense
of right and wrong during childhood
moral development occurs throughout life
as human beings pass through different
stages of growth as they mature
ethical norms are so ubiquitous that one
might be tempted to regard them as
simple common sense
on the other hand if morality were
nothing more than common sense
then why are there so many ethical
disputes and issues in our society
one plausible explanation of these
disagreements is that all people
recognize some common ethical norms
but interpret apply and balance them in
different ways in light of their own
values and life experiences
for example two people could agree that
murder is wrong but disagree about the
morality of abortion because they have
different understandings of what it
means to be a human being
most societies also have legal rules
that govern behavior
but ethical norms tend to be broader and
more informal than laws
although most societies use laws to
enforce widely accepted moral standards
ethics in law are not the same an action
may be legal but unethical
or illegal but ethical we can also use
ethical concepts and principles to
criticize
evaluate propose or interpret laws
indeed in the last century many social
reformers have urged citizens to disobey
laws they regarded as immoral or unjust
laws
peaceful civil disobedience is an
ethical way of protesting laws
or expressing political viewpoints many
different disciplines
institutions and professions
have standards for behavior that suit
their particular aims and goals
these standards also help members of the
discipline to coordinate their actions
or activities and to establish the
public's trust of the discipline
for instance ethical standards govern
conduct in medicine
law engineering and business ethical
norms also serve the aims or goals of
research
and apply to people who conduct
scientific research or other scholarly
or creative activities
there are several reasons why it is
important to adhere to ethical norms in
research first
norms promote the aims of research such
as knowledge
truth and avoidance of error
for example prohibitions against
fabricating
falsifying or misrepresenting research
data promote the truth and minimize
error
second since research often involves a
great deal of cooperation and
coordination among many different people
in different disciplines and
institutions
ethical standards promote the values
that are essential to collaborative work
such as trust accountability
mutual respect and fairness
for example many ethical norms in
research such as guidelines for
authorship
copyright and patenting policies data
sharing policies
and confidentiality rules in peer review
are designed to protect intellectual
property interests while encouraging
collaboration
most researchers want to receive credit
for their contributions
and do not want to have their ideas
stolen or disclosed prematurely
third many of the ethical norms help to
ensure that researchers can be held
accountable to the public
for instance federal policies on
research misconduct
conflicts of interest the human subjects
protections
and animal care and user necessary in
order to make sure that researchers who
are funded by public money can be held
accountable to the public
fourth ethical norms in research also
help to build public support for
research
people are more likely to fund a
research project if they can trust the
quality and integrity of research
finally many of the norms of research
promote a variety of other important
moral and social values
such as social responsibility human
rights animal welfare
compliance with the law and public
health and safety
ethical lapses in research can
significantly harm human and animal
subjects
students and the public for example
a researcher who fabricates data in a
clinical trial may harm or even kill
patients
a researcher who fails to abide by
regulations and guidelines relating to
radiation or biological safety may
jeopardize his health and safety or the
health and safety of staff and students
given the importance of ethics for the
conduct of research
it should come as no surprise that many
different professional associations
government agencies and universities
have adopted specific codes
rules and policies relating to research
ethics
these include the nuremberg code and the
world medical association's declaration
of helsinki
in summary although codes policies and
principles are very important and useful
like any set of rules they do not cover
every situation
they often conflict and they require
considerable interpretation
it is therefore important for
researchers to learn how to interpret
assess and apply various research rules
and how to make decisions
and to act ethically in various
situations
you